[Music]
there was some degree of runaway
expectations i think there was also some
degree that
they weren't extremely forthcoming with
the state of the game
the cyberpunk 2077 story is very much
kind of a story of everything that can
and will go wrong
in game development what is this bug
jackie's ai flipped out it wasn't there
before
where's my gun i i can't shoot
the release of cyberpunk 2077 in
december of 2020 will go down as one of
the most disastrous game launches in
history
and it instantly rewrote the narrative
of its celebrated developer
cd projekt red larger studios with
bigger budgets
weren't able to create the same quality
of open world game
the inside story of the making of
cyberpunk depicts a process marred by
unchecked ambition
unrealistic timelines and a focus on
marketing at the expense of development
when cd project stock was at its high it
was the largest stock in the polish
stock market
cyberpunk was supposed to be the biggest
game of 2020.
this was a game that was starring keanu
reeves this is a game that was from the
makers of the witcher 3 this was
supposed to be the big temple release of
last year and for it to become such a
disaster for so many people
i think will have pretty far-reaching
consequences
cd projekt's origins are somewhat unique
in the game's industry
in the west and japan the late 80s and
90s were dominated by games for the home
console
market and characters like mario and
sonic the hedgehog
were becoming household names the same
was not true in a post-soviet
and economically depressed poland most
gaming was done on pcs
and most games were copied and sold in
small markets around the country
you could go to the market down the
street in warsaw and and buy and sell
cds and
these two guys marcia navinsky and
mikhail kitchinsky
decided they were going to start selling
cds and they wound up striking a deal
with
the people who made a game called
balger's gate which was kind of like the
seminal role-playing game in the late
90s it was
never a business it was kind of
lifestyle so we are actually
pretty bad with counting money so you
can kind of think of it almost like nike
you know where
phil knight was selling shoes out of the
trunk of his car you know you can kind
of think about it the same way it was
you know just selling physical goods and
then evolving that into a
a much broader enterprise cd projekt
named for selling cds would move on from
just reselling games to
localizing western and japanese made
games into the polish language
but it wasn't until 2002 that the
company would make its own game
the witcher
the witcher is a huge huge series huge
fantasy series in
poland and so it was a pretty big deal
that these guys got the race to make the
video games
the witcher book series is a source of
national pride in poland
and as cd project released the witcher 2
the video game series would become an
important economic symbol for poland as
well
the cd project grad had become this
behemoth of an institution in poland
and they were really big in the polish
technology scene because
they were getting more worldwide
attention than most polish companies do
and um making a lot of money and in 2011
when barack obama came to visit
poland the prime minister actually gave
him a copy of the witcher 2.
i confess i'm not very good at video
games
but uh i've been told that uh
it is uh a great example
of poland's uh place in the new global
economy
but it would be the launch of the
witcher 3 in 2015 that would elevate cd
projekt red from representing the best
of poland
to representing the best of the games
industry
i mean really the thing people look for
first and foremost i think is that the
game is just good
and witcher 3 was just a phenomenal game
[Music]
there's a level of just storytelling an
emphasis on on making every
side quest count on top of the
atmosphere the dialogue the
character interactions the different way
stories can end
they nail that other open world games
felt
empty and enforced and the developers of
them gave excuses
as to why there couldn't be more rich
story or interactions
and the witcher 3 blew them out of the
water cd projekt red
was beloved they were seen as a studio
that was willing to make what the player
wanted and
to truly put in the love and effort
required to make a high quality game
that really connects with the people
playing with it
and the winner for game of the year 2015
is the witcher 3.
the witcher 3 would go on to win over
250 game of the year awards
but along with being a critical success
for cd projekt it was also a financial
success
estimates put the sales of witcher 3 at
around 28 million copies in 2019
a huge step up considering by 2014 the
witcher and the witcher 2
had only combined to sell 8 million
copies and with two large expansions for
the witcher 3
cd projekt also helped separate
themselves from other aaa publishers at
the time
and the game award goes oh man i have to
pay a micro
transaction to unlock that's so
stupid that this has to hold on i got
this guys here we go
other games and the most notorious um
you know one to do this was ea's uh star
wars battlefront 2.
they got really aggressive on micro
transactions in a game that already cost
at least 60 dollars you could have paid
more if you bought the premium editions
but not only was it that they were being
very aggressive and trying to get you to
spend money
but you could actually get items that
helped you win
well gamers kind of draw the line in the
sand there and they don't like them
cd project had done this phenomenal job
of marketing themselves as a gamer
friendly company
we've said this a million times and i'll
say it again we're gamers first of all
and we all like to be treated fairly
so it only makes sense that as
developers we apply the same principle
to everything we do here at cd projekt
red
so giving everyone a bunch of free dlc
was an absolutely no-brainer
they they said we're not going to sell
you dlc that's like horse armor packs
and other nonsense we're going to just
give you free stuff and then we're going
to sell big expansions as part of the
witcher 3.
and not only were they really good they
were offered at a fair price
and this was a company that was seen as
just like a company that really cared
about quality and cared about its
customers and would not do anything to
kind of screw fans over the way that
that fans see that ea and activision and
all
the other big publishers do with a
critically and financially successful
game as well as the goodwill from the
gaming audience
all the focus would shift to cd
projekt's next release
cyberpunk 2077
[Music]
it's actually funny they first announced
it through like a press release and then
they showed off a trailer
at the beginning of 2013 that was like
the cgi trailer
of like a woman and there was all sorts
of cool cyberpunk stuff flying cars lots
of stuff
but uh it wasn't really until after the
witcher 3 that cyberbunk
began really like building up this
feverish level of hype
cd projekt red though wouldn't put out
another trailer for cyberpunk
until 2018 at the e3 trade show and they
showed off
a it was like a two minute trailer of
cyberpunk looked pretty rad
and then they showed behind the scenes
for e3 attendees for
press and anyone else who could get a
score and appointment in there
they showed this 45 minute demo and it
blew people away
welcome to the gameplay demo walkthrough
of cd projekt red's upcoming title
cyberpunk 2077. the gameplay you're
about to see
is from a work in progress version of
the game everything you see
is potentially subject to change
holy
this if they can live up to what they
showed me
it's game over it all looked incredibly
impressive
they had enough action enough narrative
beats with just the right amount of
tension they touted how each of these
npcs there are thousands of them each
one
with their own daily routines and
everything we've greatly enhanced our
crowd and community systems
to create the most believable city in
any open world
game today so yeah so um people
were certainly blown away by this demo
at 23 awards and
just people left the theater just in in
uh um
what they didn't know of course is that
the demo was completely fake
fake demos are common at e3 studios put
together builds of games to show off
what they
intend the game to be like rather than
the actual state of the game
what was unique about this demo was that
it was impressively long
it kind of plays into this idea that cd
projekt is very much a marketing driven
company and so demos were really really
important to them
so it was really important that they
make this demo blow people away which it
did
but that might have come at the cost of
like some time they could have been
spending on the game
a year later at e3 2019 fans would get
another big surprise
[Applause]
whoa no way
oh
of being there of walking the streets of
the future
is really going to be breathtaking
[Applause]
[Music]
the cyberpunk trailers showed gorgeous
cities beautiful lighting really
cutting-edge technology when it comes to
the rendering of the game itself
people were very excited to be immersed
in this gorgeous cyberpunk world they
saw
over 8 million pre-orders which is a
ridiculously large amount for
any title to sell let alone pre-sell
when you saw the stock price start to go
up and up and up into the right
you know pretty pretty much in a
straight line if you just look at like
the polish stock market like the wig
index when cd projekt stock was at its
high it was the largest
stock in the in in the in the index and
that was around the time that they
announced that the game would be coming
in
april of 2020. behind the scenes people
were pretty shocked
that they were saying april i i don't
think a single person who worked on that
game
actually thought they had a chance of
coming out in
april of 2020.
so in april of 2019 i published an
article for kotaku about the making of a
game called anthem
which is a game from bioware that was
disastrous in many ways and the article
kind of ran through why that was
um afterwards i started hearing from
other developers who had
stories to share that they said sounded
a whole lot like anthems the deadline is
unrealistic
um the direction keeps changing things
are floundering we're going through a
lot of problems
um this sounds exactly like what you
wrote about anthem
around that same time perhaps
coincidentally i heard from the ceo
of cd projekt red who wanted to reach
out to me specifically to talk about
crunch
cd projekt red had a reputation for
crunch especially during the development
of witcher 3.
their management wanted them to have a
reputation
for treating workers well and not
forcing them to go through grudge
so marcia nowinski who's the co-founder
and co-ceo of cd projekt
red came to me and said hey i want to
make a vow right now that we're not
going to force anybody to crush that
people will not have to work
mandatory over time on this project
over the course of reporting bloomberg
has conducted interviews with more than
20 current and former cd projekt staff
most of whom requested anonymity so as
not to risk their careers
cd projekt declined to comment on the
process or provide interviews for this
story
the company would end up delaying the
game three different times
first pushing from an april 2020 release
to september
then november and once again to december
2020.
in order to meet the deadline the studio
would scale down the size of cyberpunk's
main city
as well as cancelling some features and
while those measures helped
developers still said they were under
significant crunch
including one former audio programmer
who claimed to work up to 13 hours a day
five days a week and stating he had seen
friends who had lost their
families over this this was not a big
secret in the office that the game was
not going to be ready
but um a similar sort of thing happened
with the witcher 3 and a similar sort of
thing happens with a lot of games where
they don't seem ready until suddenly
everything just clicks some of the best
games ever made
like were created through this process i
don't know that it's the most efficient
or the wisest way to make video games
but it's what a lot of people do
i think that management there has
genuinely tried to change it or they
said they wanted to change it
but it has proven very difficult to
change that when you make games in this
one
specific way game studios some of them
see crunch as part of their core culture
that
all of their games that they've made
under crunch have been successful
so it must be a core element to the
magic recipe for creating good games
and that's really not the case we've run
studies and seen
that at eight weeks of working 60 hours
plus
the output of a professional is
the same as if they were working 40
hours a week so
chronic overwork degrades how effective
someone is to the point where then it
becomes negative and
overworking them is just getting you
less and less
productivity and so these guys the
people at cd project
having made the witcher 3 we're kind of
riding on that high
you could call it arrogance or
confidence or whatever you want to call
it
of having made the witcher 3 and i think
that like having a certain level
confidence can certainly be a good thing
but in this case it could also be
dangerous because
it kind of blinded them to the reality
um
which was that this game wasn't going to
coalesce
cyberpunk was an ambitious project by
any standard
but for cd projekt red it was also a
very large departure from the witcher
cyberpunk was a sci-fi world rather than
a medieval fantasy
instead of a third person game that
revolved around combat with swords and
shields
cyberpunk was a first person shooter
making cyberpunk would require cd
projekt to invest in new technology
including its game engine games have to
have
a lot of logic behind them
when someone talks about developing a
game particularly in their own
engine they're not just talking about
creating art assets and setting up
quests
they're talking about building the
rendering systems
figuring out the shaders and graphics
systems and physics systems it's a lot
of
low-level work and a lot of that
low-level
work prevents some testing and
progressing of the game forward
which is sort of like if you were
driving a train while someone else was
in front of you like laying down
tracks as you went you're like trying to
make a movie while someone else is
building the camera at the same time
it's very very difficult and makes
things go super slowly and makes things
go very inefficiently and just hampers
everything
and that's actually why game development
studios prefer
open offices it's so that the team
can see what everyone else is working on
and have a passive sense of the state of
the game and how it's going
but in the final months of development
developers in cyberpunk were mostly
doing this development from their homes
across poland all malls restaurants
clubs and bars closing down
with a ban on gatherings of more than 50
people
i think because of kovid there's a lot
of issues not just in terms of
development and the timing but also the
communication side of it
and qa is a huge part quality assurance
is a huge part of game development that
a lot of people don't talk about
qa testers help run the game through its
paces
to figure out any issues it may have
then they write report tickets and send
it back to developers to fix
it's easy to underestimate the amount of
time it'll take to
fix a few bugs that you find there's a
little song
that i appreciate there's 99 little bugs
on the ball 99 little bugs
take one down patch it around 117 bugs
in the code
making that even more difficult was just
how many different platforms the game
was coming out for
due to the delays the game was
simultaneously coming out for pcs and
google's new streaming service stadia
as well as the console systems that
would now include the next generation
ps5 and xbox series x
as well as the previous generation of
consoles the ps4 and xbox one
and while the hardware and these systems
were in some cases seven years old
they represented a large market of
console gamers
particularly in the west that is really
really complicated and importing
and dealing with like optimization
across the platforms can be really
really challenging
and when you are a company a cd projekt
red is that primarily develops on
pcs um and is used to making games for
pcs
um sometimes not everybody in the studio
will be
like uh even bothering playing the
console versions
as is what happened here and what we saw
with cyberpunk was a case where
the console versions the last gen
console versions were just a complete
mess
and when management announced in october
that the game had gone gold
meaning it was ready to be pressed into
disks there were still
major bugs being discovered exhausted
programmers would scramble to fix as
many of these problems as they could
via a day one patch and cd projekt did
their best to control
which versions of the game would be seen
before the release date
so with a video game review process you
are
sent first some guidelines
here's what to reveal and what not to
reveal when the game launches
what spoilers are important and what
aren't and
they give you these guidelines alongside
an nda or some kind of embargo
when i read through the embargo and the
restrictions i realized just how
restrictive it was
so reviews came out a few days before
the game came out and they seemed pretty
good
um but reviewers all cautioned that
they said hey cd projekt only let us
have the pc version
um they didn't let us have access to the
ps4 and xbox one
versions of the game the thinking at cd
projekt was maybe
okay we have a patch plan that maybe
reviewers didn't have access to like a
day one patch so
we don't want them to show footage of
the game before it's ready to go and
maybe they thought
hey the console versions they're going
to get a patch
like the day before it comes out so so
we don't want to talk about that we
don't want to show those versions just
yet
but no matter what the rationale was
behind cd projekt doing this
ultimately it turned into the true
scope of the game's problems being
hidden
on december 10th of 2020 the game was
released and it didn't take long for the
problems become public
oh no it works he [ __ ] t
post softy
yeah i mean obviously the t posing stuff
uh can kind of can be kind of funny
but when it keeps happening it really
starts to
break your immersion my car would spawn
where another car was already at and so
they would like collide and then
both cars would explode or something
there are a lot of like people's quests
ending unexpectedly or like ais
appearing one
one common one was that um someone who
was supposed to be just like
uh with you on one mission like a buddy
with you on one mission
would just follow you for the entire
game and just inexplicably they would
just be around with like with you
one hilarious bug that i discovered when
i first loaded up the game
um on launch day was there were tiny
trees covering every single thing
in the game i was playing through the
prologue and there were just little
trees everywhere
i did try cyberpunk 2077 on playstation
4
and for me it's as good as employable
with that level of performance
there are segments where it runs at like
25 to 30 frames
but then there are segments where it's
clear the frame rates are at like your
15s and 20s
and aiming with an analog stick while
frame rates are
rising and dipping it's simply
impossible
the experience on those last gen
consoles will be so bad that sony would
take the unprecedented action of
removing the game from its digital
stores i mean the stock started selling
off
little by little and then a lot by a lot
you know it kind of cascaded to a point
and then once we saw
sony turn off the ability to buy the
game and offer refunds
that was kind of the the the drop that
the bottom fell out yeah so
um about a few weeks after the game came
out
um the cd project's co-founder and
co-ceo marcin navinsky
came on a video and he spoke for about
five minutes and
tried to address point by point like
some of the things that people have been
talking about
please don't fault any of our teams for
what happened
they all are incredibly talented and
hardworking
myself and the board are the final
decision makers and it was our call to
release the game
i was just kind of justifying their
actions and apologizing and
and vowing that they would fix this game
and they wanted to
regain people's trust etc etc
cd projekt redwood released three
hotfixes in december
and two more patches in the coming
months in their apology video
cd projekt red would also release a road
map for their future plans
for both their tlc content and future
patches
although exactly when these things would
come was a little vague
it's to be seen what they do i mean i
think to save face
they have to do what they can to fix
cyberpunk but how much
resources they dedicate to premium dlc
expansions
to the online mode is still kind of up
in the air we have to see what they say
about that
or do you kind of just do what you can
stop the bleeding and just move on to
what you're for you know
at what point do you have to just say
we're gonna nip this in the butt and
move on
um is is going to be a lot of focus for
a lot of investors in the next few
months
there's a lot of precedent in the video
game industry for redemption stories for
video games
coming out in a pretty bad shape and
then
getting fixed patched updated added to
over time we've seen it with no man's
sky we've seen it with destiny we've
seen it with final fantasy 14 a lot of
these online games
one thing that they could do is say
anyone who bought the game will get like
the dlc for free as an apology from us
there are a lot of things they could do
i think to win back the fans
i think it's apparent looking at the
release of cyberpunk 2077
and the reception of it that gamers
overall
are much more tolerant about pushback
release deadlines
and understand that a game that is
rushed or built
under crunch is less likely to come out
in the state that they would like it
to i make videos about these companies
and
it's not because i want them to fail
it's because i want them to get better
i hope cd projekt looks at everything
that's happening and just
actually make some changes i'm going to
quote shiguru miyamoto from nintendo
he's like the father
of super mario a delayed game is
eventually good
a rush game is never good and this is a
company that was not
lacking for money they had plenty of
cash and so the decision to not do so
will go down in history as a very poor
[Music]
[Music]
one
you